hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast
Washington's new opioid prescribing
rules it is presented by Blake Marsh
MPAC MBE deputy director in the office
of Health Professions at the Washington
Department of Health I am Judy O'Rourke
of laberd's and I'll be your moderator
for today's event we're delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots leopards is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before I
begin I'd like to remind everyone this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want
anytime you want during the presentation
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and type your questions into the drop
down box it appears on the screen our
speaker will respond to your questions
via email if you have any trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the ask a question box to let us know
that you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits
tab located in the top right corner of
the presentation window and follow the
process to pin your credits please join
me in welcoming Blake Marsh I will now
turn the presentation over to him
Thank You Judy I appreciate the
opportunity to be here with leverage
today talking about opioid rules that
the state of Washington has just
finished promulgating in pursuant to
House bill 14:27 here in state of
Washington let me go ahead and just walk
very briefly through the topic areas for
today's discussion I do want to give a
little bit of background on the opioid
crisis both nationally and how it's
affected us here in Washington State as
well as talk a little bit about some of
the precursors to how we got to this
rulemaking process I will go through the
highlights of the rules that have been
adopted by our boards and commissions as
well as talk about the next steps that
are going to take place in the coming
months and that will also include what
some of the things that we're doing with
regard to education and outreach and I
finally want to end up with some
takeaways some kind of summary points
about what the rules are and are not
intended to do and of course we'll do
questions and answers at the end
so to begin I've put a slide up here on
the screen of age-adjusted rates of drug
overdose deaths by state this is
nationally this is not just opioid drugs
this is all overdose deaths but it does
give you a way to kind of do a
comparative analysis about the the
problems that are going on with overdose
in in our country part of the reason why
this involves all drugs and not just
opioids is that different states
track causes of death and and death
records a little differently so it's not
necessarily it's not you're not able to
necessarily break out opioid related
deaths from other kinds of overdose
deaths but it does show that there are
problem areas across the country but
this is really a problem that affects
all of us nationally
the next slide relates to overdose
deaths raised and this is specific to
opioid overdose deaths in Washington
stays between 2012 and 2016 and it's
broken up by county again you can see
that while there are some counties where
there is a bigger problem with opioid
overdoses than others that all states
are all parts of our states have a
problem they are grappling with this
issue of opioid overdose deaths one
thing I would point out is that some of
the counties in eastern Washington for
example if you look at extreme
southeastern Washington in Columbia
County those counties are very sparsely
populated so while the numbers of opioid
overdose deaths are are high and that is
reflected in a deeper red color there
are very few people in that county and
so you have to kind of take that into
consideration as you think about small
numbers issues
the next slide list it's a graphic of
opioid-related overdoses in Washington
between 2000 and 2017 and what this does
is it provides a graphic representation
of how we've been battling prescription
overdose deaths in Washington and what
some of the outcomes have been you can
see that beginning in about 2011 if you
look at the blue line in the middle that
prescription overdose deaths related to
opioids have actually decreased a fair
amount unfortunately if you look at the
lines down at the bottom of the of the
graph you'll see heroin overdoses and
and synthetic drugs like fentanyl
overdoses and those are actually
increasing they have kind of
unfortunately made up the progress that
we have had in reducing the number of
opioid overdose deaths
description of the opioid overdose
deaths
slide is a representation of how opioid
overdose deaths are really just the tip
of the iceberg in Washington and I've
really find this presentation to be
valuable because what it shows is that
for every death that we had in the state
of Washington and I believe this is the
2016 number so six hundred and ninety
four deaths in 2016 you have two opioid
overdose hospitalizations you also have
21 substance abuse treatment admissions
and then down at the bottom for every
death
you have 373 people ages 12 years and
older who are misusing opioids they're
using them non-medically I think that
that's a fairly startling statistic when
you think about it so that we are
certainly concerned about opioid
overdose deaths but we also have to make
sure that we are focusing on the the
excess supply of opioids in society
because a lot of people are using them
and they just they are not they have not
overdosed yet and that's the thing we
have to try and do is to prevent them
from overdosing so let me talk a little
bit about opioid prescribing rules and
the priests precursors to the rule
making process
in 2015 our state's opioid response
workgroup which is an interagency
workgroup comprised of people working on
various aspects of opioid treatment came
together and created a statewide plan to
try and address issues related to opioid
prescribing and it's a group that's
hosted by us here at the Department of
Health and we laid out a number of
different goals you can see there on the
screen to try and address different
aspects of the opioid crisis we were
very fortunate in that that really kind
of served as a action for our governor
who in 2016
issued an executive order addressing the
opioid crisis in the state of Washington
and you can see some of the key goals
from the order here stay from
prescribing practices really expanding
the use of non opioid alternatives and
those are both pharmacologic and
nonpharmacologic as ways to treat pain
expanding access to medication assisted
treatment as well as increasing use of
the prescription monitoring program or
PMP
in the wake of that executive order
during our 2017 legislative session
there were a number of different bills
that were introduced by members of our
legislature and is currently is often
the case with many big topics like this
when you have a lot of legislative
activity the legislative leadership
usually finds a way to consolidate a lot
of that work into a single bill and that
bill becomes the vehicle for moving
forward those policy goals and in this
particular case in 2017 the bill is
House bill 14 27 and I've listed the key
components on to the bill over on the
right really it divides into two main
hemispheres of work and the one
hemisphere is the creation and expansion
of opioid prescribing rules that are
under the auspices of our five boards
prescribing boards and commissions in
the state of Washington and then the
other hemisphere of work really had to
do more with expanding access to our
prescription monitoring program data in
a variety of ways the other precursor I
want to talk about is in 2010 we had a
bill passed in the legislature that
directed those same five boards and
commissions I mentioned earlier the
Dental Commission the medical Commission
the nursing Commission the board of
osteopathic medicine and surgery and the
Podiatric Medical Board it directed them
to work together to create chronic
non-cancer pain management rules by June
30th of 2011
now those rules at that time were
limited to chronic care and it excluded
both acute and palliative care the rules
included a specific specific limit on
pain management prescribing and if you
go above that threshold it required you
to do a consultation with a pain
management specialist now they're also
provided for certain exceptions to that
rule but also the rules included
education training requirements both for
pain management specialists and others
providing pain management care
and other practice standards the bill
also required that in developing those
chronic non-cancer pain rules that the
five boards and commissions consult with
the agency medical directors group here
in the state of Washington or a and B G
our Department of Health the University
of Washington and the professional
associations for each of the five
organizations which the five boards and
commissions
so moving on to the new prescribing
requirements
so in 2017 and House bill 1427 five the
same five boards and commissions were
directed to adopt general opioid
prescribing rules and that included a
number of exemptions available for them
for things like education training
prescribing level patient panel and
practice environment again just as with
the chronic non-cancer pain rules 2011
the five boards and commissions were
directed to consider newly revised
agency medical directors group opioid
guidelines and CDC guidelines the five
boards and commissions were also
authorized to work with professional
associations for Department of Health
and the University of Washington with a
goal of adopting rules by January 1 of
2019 so the department in trying to help
the five boards and commissions move
forward on this convened a task force
and the task force was comprised of two
representatives from each of the five
boards and commissions as well as two ex
officio representatives from our
pharmacy Commission and we held a series
of seven all-day stakeholder workshops
once a month between September of last
year and March of 2018 in order to
invite technical experts to come and
provide information to our task force in
order to take input from prescribers and
health systems and health plans
hospitals as well as to get input from
patients in the public and we did have a
patient community of chronic pain
patient community that came to each of
the meetings and were a very important
part of the process now the task force
was not specifically authorized under
1427 to promulgate rules so what we
asked them to do was to debate the
issues evaluate the evidence and then
develop a draft set of boilerplate rules
that each board or Commission could then
adopt or make minor modifications to and
then adopt so each of those of five
boards and Commission had to adopt their
own set of
but it was rules were heavily influenced
by the work the task force
few exclusions to the opioid prescribing
rules the rules do not apply to any
patients with cancer related pain and I
will say that one of the areas where
there are there is a difference amongst
the rule sets is that some boards and
commissions opted to say that no matter
how long post curative treatment you
were still suffering from cancer pain
you would be exempt from the chronic
pain rules or from that their opioid
prescribing rules other boards and
commissions chose to look at it a little
differently and say that if you or are
two years post curative treatment if
your sufferer still suffering pain
that's residual from the cancer or the
cancer treatment that you can still have
opioid therapy but it would simply fall
under chronic pain rules so generally
speaking anybody who's actively engaged
in cancer treatment and has pain as a
result of that would be exempt from
these rules
Adam where there's an exclusion is the
provision of palliative hospice or other
end-of-life care
in addition hospital inpatient
treatments are exempted from the rules
as our provision of procedural pre
medications
so the rules are divided up into a
number of different phases of care and
I'm going to walk through several of
these new phases where we've done new
rulemaking on this slide the first is
just acute non-operative pain and that's
defined as pain during a period of 0 to
6 weeks as well as perioperative there
and the requirements you can see on this
on the slide include history and
physical examination screening for risk
factors intensity of pain
specifically considering whether or not
there are alternatives to opioids that
may be useful in lieu of just defaulting
to opioids reevaluating treatment where
recovery may not be going as expected
and involve using an object objective
metrics we want to make sure that you
know patients recoveries are being
tracked in kind of a clinically
objective way and this is for both acute
and perioperative phases of care
the subacute phase you'll see is is
similar in many respects to acute and
not acute not operative and
perioperative phases the difference is
that with the subacute phase and this is
not always the case but but I think in
many cases it will be borne out that if
a patient is is progressing into the
subacute phase it may be because there
is some aspect of their recovery that's
not going as expected and so what the
task force and what the boards and
commissions really had in mind here was
that you still need to be doing the same
kinds of proper treatments as you would
an acute or perioperative but you really
need to stop and think about whether or
not if the patient head is still not
recovering as you would expect whether
or not prescribing more opioids or
higher doses of opioids is indicated or
whether or not you need to take a look
at some other options such as screening
the patient for any risky or aberrant
behaviors doing some biological specimen
testing or maybe sending that person to
to to some kind of specialist or consult
doing some kind of consultation because
ultimately what you want to do is you
want to make sure that you're not just
increasing dosages and potentially
putting that person at risk for creating
an addiction
this next slide lays out what the
prescribing limits are for the acute
perioperative and subacute phases of
care I want to emphasize here that
limits may be exceeded based on
prescribers putting written
documentation in the clinical record of
an exceptional need so a lower amount
than the state limit may often be
appropriate for less significant pain we
really expect that that these limits
shouldn't typically be be reached so if
prescribed prescribers should still use
their clinical judgment and if a lower
amount is appropriate in order to deal
with the pain then that's the amount
that it should be written for and
conversely prescribers should not on a
ongoing basis on on a general basis be
writing exceptional prescriptions over
these amounts
I will point out as you look at this
table is that there's a great amount of
consistency between osteopathic
physicians and PAS allopathic positions
and pas AR MPs and podiatric physicians
our dental partners are still finalizing
their rules they have one supplemental
hearing coming up in December but they
have proposed combining acute and
perioperative care given the nature of
their practices that really what you're
talking about when you prescribing
opioids are things like oral surgery
root canals extractions that sort of
thing they also have had the benefit of
some additional research work done here
in the state of Washington by the Robert
breed collaborative and that
collaborative looked in recent years at
dental opioid prescribing and proposed
some guidelines and so the Dental
Commission has added a additional
requirement that for patients under the
age of 25 that you really should be
limiting the amount of the opioid
prescription to 12 tablets
unless they're again there's an
exceptional need in which case you can
document that in the patient record
I'm not going to spend excessive amount
of time on this slide simply because
many of the chronic opioid prescribing
rules remain largely unchanged from the
rules that were promulgated in 2011 they
are important rules however they
stipulate things like having to have
written treatment agreements with your
patient doing periodic review and that
there is that that consultation
requirement when your patient is being
prescribed more than 120 milligrams per
day morphine equivalent dose but there
are a couple of things that have been
added to the chronic section of the
opioid rules one has to do with tapering
or changing a patient's prescription and
the other has to do with patients who
are on high doses of opioids and when
they move to new prescribers
a moment on this idea of tapering the
rules say that prescribers should
consider tapering changing or
discontinuing or referring for a
substance abuse disorder evaluation when
a patient meets one of these several
conditions and they're things like if
the patient requests it if there's some
kind of deterioration in pain or
function if the patient is non-compliant
or obviously if there is some kind of
evidence of misuse abuse or an adverse
event but it's important to understand
that this is really a requirement that
the prescriber consider tapering or
changing it's not a requirement that
that people be hard tapered
so with respect to
who are on high doses of opioids and
being able to move to a new prescriber
one of the things that we heard when we
were in our stakeholder workshops was a
lot of fear from pain patients about
what happens if my prescriber retires
what happens if they decide they don't
want to prescribe opioids anymore what
happens if they don't want to do pain
management anymore what happens if they
if they move to another state and I need
to move to a new prescriber and
by contrast one of the things we heard
from prescribers is a lot of concern or
fear about taking on a new patient
especially when they're on high doses of
opioids so what we've tried to do with
this particular rule is is emphasize
that it's really normally appropriate
for practitioners to just maintain
dosages for brand new patient now we
want prescribers to eventually evaluate
whether or not those dosages should be
changed over time but the law provides
the rules provide a limited exemption
for 90 days where you have a patient who
is compliant patient who has been stable
they're on high doses and they've got
good pain control and good functionality
so basically if you have a patient who
has been on the stable dose for many
years and they come into your office it
gives you a little bit of a window of
opportunity to evaluate that patient
before you decide whether or not any
changes are appropriate in their
treatment plan
one of the other provisions of the rule
is continuing education
all professions require now in the rules
that professionals must complete a
one-time continuing a value or excuse me
one time continuing education
requirement and they have to do it by
either the end of their first full
continuing education cycle after the
rules take effect or for new prescribers
that are newly licensed in their first
full Cee cycle and the requirements are
for four hours for nursing three hours
for dental professionals and for medical
professionals osteopathic professionals
and podiatric professionals one hour
apiece
this slide just highlights several of
the other provisions in the rules as I
said earlier there is specific emphasis
on alternative treatments and really
what we're trying to get prescribers to
do is to consider and use clinical
judgment around other types of
treatments like physical therapy massage
chiropractic acupuncture or even just
using other kinds of non-opioid
pharmacologic modalities like NSAIDs and
acetaminophen which are in some cases
shown to actually provide better pain
better pain relief than opioids so we
don't want people to default to opioids
instead of the first and only treatment
modality for pain we do want to have
prescribers and patients having
conversations about the risks of opioids
and so we've put in their requirement at
certain thresholds during treatment that
there has to be a conversation
documented in the patient record about
the risks of opioids how patients can
safely and securely store opioids and
making sure that they dispose of unused
medications properly and what we've
actually done in the department here is
as part of our education and outreach
campaign we've provided a series of one
pagers that prescribers can use to have
that conversation with patients now they
don't have to use it but we've provided
it as a resource for prescribers in
order to to help have that conversation
with patients
we also have included in the rules Co
prescribing requirements and these look
at not just whether or not it's
appropriate to prescribe opioids with
things like benzodiazepines or sedative
hypnotics where you have to kind of
exercise special care because of the
additive and synergistic effects of
prescribing both of them together but
you also need to think about Co
prescribing in the context of someone
who's on medication assisted treatment
so if they're getting buprenorphine or
naltrexone and they have an acute
episode or they're having breakthrough
pain how do you manage opioid
prescribing with medication assisted
treatment and certainly also if you have
patients who are on high doses of
opioids is it appropriate to do a
prescription for naloxone as well
finally we have some special advice for
patients certain patient populations
patients under the age of 25 pregnant
women aging populations where opioids
can have a more pronounced effect and
again acute care or perioperative care
for patients who are on chronic opioid
therapy
you
so the next couple of slides deal with
required registration and protects of
the prescription monitoring program in
Washington and the this was perhaps the
most intensely debated element of the
proposed rules by the task force and by
the individual boards and commissions
what the task force ended up
recommending to the individual boards
Commission's is a floor for safe
practice and they they came to a certain
set of agreements but they also said we
encourage boards and commissions if they
feel like they need to go further to go
further and that's what happened in most
cases there is a requirement in the
rules that if you prescribe opioids that
this may also sometimes include include
benzodiazepines or other scheduled drugs
then you have to register with the
prescription monitoring program
so this slide summarizes the
similarities and differences in where
the five boards and commissions ended up
with respect to checking prescription
monitoring program data for the acute
and perioperative and sub acute phases
and I'll start over on the left and just
be very brief about this the osteopathic
physicians and PAS made it very simple
they simply said we believe that you
should check the prescription monitoring
program every single time you've issue a
prescription so it's every script every
time for physicians they recommended
doing a check as the first acute or
perioperative refill and then trained at
transition so between acute and subacute
and between sub acute and chronic they
also recommend in their rules or
requiring their rules that it where you
have PMP data integrated into health
systems or hospitals electronic medical
records that you need to check at every
prescription for acute or perioperative
and that's very similar to what the
podiatric physicians the second column
on the right landed on now they actually
said the second acute or perioperative
refill they want to align their rules
with physicians and so will in 2019
probably be engaging in rulemaking to
make their requirements consistent with
physicians similarly
on the far right-hand column you have
the proposed rules for dentist and
they've decided to allow after debating
a number of different positions to align
themselves with the physicians as well
so again first a cuter perioperative
refill between phases and then if you
have integrated PMP and medical record
capacity then you check every town for
AR NPS it's just a little bit different
they they said that the check should
come at the first acute or perioperative
prescription unless there's some reason
that you can't and then you need to
document that in the medical record and
then if you don't check it first
prescription you need to check at the
first refill
again between phases and they also added
a provision at the bottom that for for
elective surgeries you need to check the
patient's preoperatively through the
prescription monitoring program or if
it's a non elective surgery then you
need to check by discharge
it's regard to chronic opioid therapy
and and prescription monitoring programs
checked this slide kind of summarizes
that for professions other than
osteopathic physicians and pas because
again they said they wanted people to
check their their licensees to check
every script every time so for the other
professions you need to employ kind of a
risk stratification model where you're
checking at least quarterly for
high-risk patients at least
semi-annually for moderate risk patients
and at least annually for low-risk
patients now of course you should be
checking if there is any amber in
behavior on the part of your patient or
again if they're in that situation where
they are going through some kind of
acute episode or perioperative care you
need to be checking more often and
ultimately the message here is that the
value of the prescription monitoring
program and making sure that you're
providing safe care to patients is
beyond question so beyond the
requirements laid out in rule to check
the PMP we strongly encourage it we
think it's a it's a good reasonable
mechanism to make sure that your
patients are are safe it prevents you
know any potential concerns about drug
interactions and it also is a way to
guard against the potential for dr.
shopping
so in terms of next steps and takeaways
here are the next steps or the timeline
for the rules and you can see that in
August and September the the five boards
and commissions held public hearings
they had public comment on their
proposed rules four out of the five
boards and commissions adopted rules and
those were finalized and submitted to
our state's office of the Code revisor
in the legislature in order to begin the
process of codifying them for three of
the boards and commissions you can see
the final rules are were effective on
November 1st so for the nursing
Commission for the osteopathic board for
the Podiatric Medical Board all of their
rules went into effect on November 1st
during their hearing the medical
Commission stipulated a specific
effective date for their rules of
January 1 2019 so their rules are final
but their rules do not take effect until
the 1st of the year now in between now
and the end of the year we are at that
we've been actively engaged in doing
education and outreach to try and help
inform patients prescribers and the
public about what's in the rules and
what's not in the rules I mean that
process will continue and I'll talk more
about that in the next slide I do want
to again inform you that our colleagues
from the Dental Commission did make some
changes at their hearing in September
and so they're going through a
supplemental hearing process that is
anticipated to occur on December 7th so
we are still hopeful that they will have
rules adopted by the end of the year we
will have to see what happens in that
hearing but hopefully in the near future
their rules will become final as well
in terms of education and outreach we've
done extensive work going back all the
way to middle of the summer and well and
like I say here on the flag we've been
focusing primarily on prescribers
patients the public but we do recognize
that we have a lot of other audiences
out there that we need to reach out to
and so some of our other key partners
include talking with different schools
and training programs around the state
partnering with the professional
association and helping provide
information to them so they can provide
it out to their memberships working with
tribal communities in the state of
Washington working with other state
agencies as well as health plans and
health systems and we're also making
sure that we are communicating with
policy leaders about the final rules and
making sure that they have information
that they need as well some of our key
messages and methods for communicating
out with people include doing email
listserv messages we've totally revamped
our project website and what we've done
is we've put all kinds of information on
the website I'll give you the URL and a
minute for that but we are really trying
to make sure that people know that they
can go to the website for for just about
any information that they need on these
rules we've done this whole series of
handouts in one pagers both focusing on
profession by profession what are the
highlights of the rules so we have a
series of toolkits on our website and if
you are an ARNP for example you can go
and click on the nursing toolkit and
you'll find a four-page handout that
goes into the key points around the
nursing rules and so it's customized to
your individual profession in addition
as I mentioned earlier we've put
together a series of patient
notification one-pagers and we also have
those on our website and we have a
patient part of our page as well where
patients can access information about
the rules and those patient notification
one-pagers are located on there as well
as a video from some of our pain
management some of our pain advocates as
I mentioned earlier that participated in
our state
process so some of the other things
we're doing we've got postcard mailers
that we've sent out to licensees we
recently reached out to about one
hundred and thirteen thousand licensees
in the state of Washington I will be
doing some more later on particularly as
the Dental Commission finalized as its
rules we'll be reaching out to the
dental community I mentioned we've done
video modules so for each different
discipline each different health
profession we have a video module about
eighteen to twenty minutes that goes
into the highlights of the rules as well
we're doing a large number of
presentations at conferences and events
and so on again I'm very excited that
I've got the opportunity here through
labyrinth to be able to provide this
information to you and we're publishing
newsletter articles as well so it's
really a multi-faceted approach to
trying to get to our audiences and make
sure that they understand what's in the
rules and what's not on the rules
so just to begin to close our
presentation here
takeaways that I wanted to leave with
you some of the things that you know
we've heard throughout the process you
know we've tried to
highlight or highlight that that's not
really our goal and so some of the
things that that we've heard you know
that where people are concerned about
the route new rules do not really make
significant changes to many of the
existing chronic pain rules those rules
were modified slightly updated a little
bit but but no major changes were made
to those the rules don't set hard limits
on the number of pills that can be
prescribed or the number of prescription
days again the seven-day limit for acute
and the 14-day limits for perioperative
and for subacute are our limits but they
can be exceeded if there's an
exceptional need that's documented in
patient record
the new rules don't require the patients
prescriptions be tapered to a certain
morphine equivalent dose or that people
be weaned off of opioids I talk with
pain patients on a regular basis who are
concerned about are they going to see a
change in their and their prescriptions
are they they're very concerned about am
I going to be able to get things to
control my pain and to give me function
and the rules don't require that
and these rules don't set a trap for
prescribers as well it was very
important to the task force and to the
boards and commissions that people
understand that these rules are there to
make sure that you know what the minimum
standards are for safe and effective
practice and appropriate practice but
it's certainly not meant for to instill
fear in physicians or the prescribers
that if you miss one little check or you
fail to document one little thing that
you're going to lose your license this
is about making sure that you're
consistently doing the right things in
terms of a proper history and evaluation
limiting dosages to the minimum amount
needed to control pain and providing
proper documentation and and doing
consultation other things when it's
appropriate as well as looking at
alternatives to opioids for pain control
so with regard to think you do need to
know about what the rules do
they do allow for exceeding the state
limits as I've mentioned when there's a
documented reason they do promote
judicious use of opioids and promote
alternative pain control methods and one
of the things we we went into this rule
process striving to do was to achieve a
balance and there's really not three
competing goals but more of a
three-legged stool and it involves that
we wanted to make sure that patients who
needed opioids in order to control their
pain and to achieve some level of
function but still get safe and
appropriate opioid therapy so one leg
was making sure the patient still could
get access to opioids in a safe and
appropriate way balancing that with
making sure that we were curbing
excessive opioid prescribing that leads
to misuse abuse overdose and death and
doing all of this while we're
prohibiting or preventing disincentives
for prescribers to treat patients
because what we didn't want to do was
make this so owners that prescribers
didn't want to treat patients anymore so
it's really making sure that patients
have access to appropriate care that
we're curbing misuse and abuse and that
you know they were avoiding
disincentives in the system
finally we really think that appropriate
care depends upon prescribers and
patients having good communication and
sharing responsibility and that's part
of the reason why we built that patient
notification language into the rules as
well and again the Department offers one
pagers that prescribers can use to help
facilitate that conversation you don't
have to use our one pagers if you want
to use a different one page or use other
information from other other great
sources out there that's fine but it is
important that you have that
conversation with patients
ultimately one of the things we heard
from our advocates in the process for
the pain community was that patients
need you and you need to be able to
continue to treat patients with care and
thought I thought that that was an
appropriate message on which to end the
presentation I thank you for the
opportunity to talk with you about our
rules and I'm happy to take any
questions I have provided for you on
this last slide here the URL for our
project it's WWD ohw a gob slash opioid
prescribing and we've located on there
kind of a summary of the process that we
went through to complete these rules you
can find the rules language on the
website as well as all of our education
and outreach materials and with that I
will turn back over to Judy Thank You
Blake for that informative presentation
we'll now start the Q&A portion of the
webinar and we'll address some of the
most commonly asked questions by our of
yours so if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button or speaker
we'll follow up with your questions via
email let's get started first question
is regarding the chronic pain rules and
tapering our prescribers required to pay
per patients
so that's an important question because
some of what I've heard from pain
patients is that out of fear or out of
not knowing what's in the rules
prescribers are starting to train
forcibly taper patients the rules only
require that physicians or other
prescribers consider tapering in that
various defined set of circumstances so
again if a patient requests that their
prescription be changed or tapered then
that that would be a time to do it if
there is some kind of evidence that the
patient is you know engaging an aberrant
behavior or risky behavior or there's
been some kind of an adverse event some
kind of an overdose then it's important
that the prescriber really reconsider
whether or not that patient needs to
continue to be on that level of opioid
therapy but again it does not require
that prescribers forcibly taper people
and it does not require that they taper
them to any particular level as well so
I know there's a lot of confusion around
a 120 milligrams per day working
equivalent dose and I've had people say
I have to get do I have to get all my
patients to 120 meed no you don't so I
appreciate the question is something we
want clinicians to use their best
judgment on but they do not have to
taper patients hey thanks for that the
next one is do prescribers have to
document the results of the prescription
monitoring program check in the patient
record
they do and this is also kind of a good
question that I've gotten from people
and they've asked do I have to actually
run the check and put it in the patient
record and the answer is that's
certainly one way that you can document
that you did it is to actually
incorporate the check into the patient
record you don't have to however and
it's important also to know that that
while the prescriber is required to
review the prescription monitoring
program check they don't have to run it
so within Washington system if you're
the prescriber you haven't if you're a
physician for example and you have a
nurse or a medical assistant who works
for you you can go into our PMP and you
can designate those those other staff to
run checks on your behalf and it's
perfectly appropriate under the rules to
have a medical assistant or a nurse run
a check for you but you have to review
it and you have to document in the in
the records that you did review it and
again that can be as simple as making a
note that check was done on this date
and you know here's what I observed or
you can actually incorporate the the
report into the record but that that
part is really up to the clinician and
what they want to do theirs and so yes
it is required to be documented but
there are variety of different ways that
you can achieve that
okay we have time for one more question
our practitioner is still required under
the new rules to seek a pain management
consultation when patients in chronic
opioid therapy exceeded dealing morphine
equivalent dose of 120 milligrams per
day
they are there that that particular
provision in the rules has not changed
from the 2011 rules that were
promulgated by the five boards and
commissions so if a patient is on a dose
as a patient undergoing chronic opioid
therapy and they're on a dose of opioids
exceeding 120 milligrams per day working
to quit one dose then there is a
requirement that that the prescriber
have a pain management consultation with
a pain specialist now there are certain
provisions in the rules and those have
been again there they've been there
since 2011 that are exceptions to that
requirement and some of those exceptions
relate to the patient's so if the
patient if it is a prescriber if you
make good-faith attempts to reach out to
a pain management specialist and you're
not able to connect with someone and you
document those in the patient record
then and and your patient needs
continued opioid therapy it may be
appropriate then to go forward and and
continue to treat that patient at that
level above 120 milligrams per day
indeed there are also some requirements
or something to excusing some exceptions
in the rule that relate to the
prescriber so if you complete a certain
amount of C II you can and you're in
you're just a treating physician or
treating clinician you can be exempted
from the consultation requirement so
there are very specific education and
experience requirements to be a pain
management specialist but if you but you
separately can meet a more limited
number of continuing education
requirements if you're just a treating
practitioner and that that education and
experience will give you the ability to
treat patients without having to go and
get a pain management consultation but
absent going to those extra steps of
getting that additional education yes
the existing requirement that a pain
management consultation occur at over
120 milligrams per day mu D still exists
in the rules
well thank you for that I would like to
once again thank Blake Marsh for his
presentation would also like to thank
lab roots for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through February 15 to 2019
you'll receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's event that
is all for now thank you for joining us
we hope to see you again soon bye